عشره سيارات الاسعاف هذه حول مقر الاسعاف
مركونه وليست في الخدمه بسبب اضراب اطقم
الاسعاف وهذه مجموعه من بين اكثر من 20
الف مسعف على خطوط الاعتصام ليوم واحد بعد
فشل مفاوضات الحكومه مع نقابتهم في
الاتفاق على رفع الاجور
الاف المرضى الغيت مواعيد علاجاتهم غير
الطارئه بسبب الاضراب الذي سيؤدي بحسب
اعتراف النقابه الى المزيد من الاذى
للمرضى فيما تنصح هيئه الصحه باستخدام
خدماتها بحكمه
لقد عمل ممثل خدمه الاسعاف في لندن بجديه
تامه في الاسبوعين الماضيين واجتمعوا مع
ادارتها هيئه الاسعاف لوضع خطه التعامل مع
مكالمات الطوارئ للحصول على رعايه اللازمه
عندما يحتاجونها مثل ما شاهدنا اليوم ترك
مسعفون الصفوف الاعتصام للقيام بذلك
الاتهامات المتبادله بين حزب العمال ورئيس
الحكومه تزايدت مع التوسع الاضرابات وقد
هاجم ريش سوناك حزب العمال لدعمه
الاضرابات في جلسه لمساءله الاسبوعيه
للحكومه
الطوارئ هذه يجب ان يعتمد الناس على حد
ادنى من الرعايه المنقذه للحياه لماذا
يعترض على ذلك
لا يوجد حد ادنى للخدمه لانكم دمرتم قطاع
الصحه
[تصفيق]
اضراب اخر لعمال الاسعاف من جدول في
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر الحالي وقبله
سيتوقف الممرضون عن العمل اليومين الاسبوع
المقبل ومن شان ذلك كله ان يفاقم الاضطراب
غير المسبوق الذي يشهده قطع الصحه
فاجمعنا في بريطانيا على ضروره حل ازمه
الاجور خصوصا بعد جلوس الحكومه مطلع
الاسبوع لاول مره مع قاده النقابات لكن
اشتراط الحكومه ربه اي زياده بتحصيل
الانتاجيه وتمسكا النقابات بمطالبها سيؤدي
الى مفاهمه الاضطرابات في قطاع الصحه
المنهكي اصلا مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن